what does a submissive woman do for her
man
everything
what does that mean you know like
packing his bag
unpacking his bag
um
just making sure all the things that he
wants and i i pretty much read his mind
so it's like if i know you
and i study you like i know how you are
in the morning i know how you are about
midday i know when you're in this mood
what you need like before you can ever
ask me for something i'm already on it i
mean
he's spoiled and you know when i talked
to my girlfriends about it i was like oh
how are you guys doing i'm just like
girl he's rotten i'm like he's spoiled
rotten like he's ryan but i love that
like i want him to be there i think my
biggest flex is how i treat my man and
i've been known to love people back to
health and sometimes it's very draining
but
my love is my superpower and i used to
hate that about myself but now it's like
i'm just embracing it like that's who i
am like if i love you i can heal you
it's your joy it is my joy you know i i
love to see him eating the meal that i
cooked i love seeing him sleep easy
every night like clockwork i scratch
this man's back to sleep and i know when
he's asleep because i can tell when his
breathing changes and some people might
think that's psychotic but that's like i
just know that's when i'm like oh i can
stop now but i find joy in being your
rest you know so know what that means
and that works for us because
he wants what i have to offer
so um question for the panel
what is submission to you and is that
something that
you the ladies would do in a
relationship that you would require i
like i don't even know
i don't even insight as an impulsive i
don't know you just you just tell me
what that means
for you so what do you start and for me
yeah submission is something that will
happen naturally okay and you feel safe
when the dynamic is healthy so yeah
okay
so would you be okay with all the things
that she said in the video like
scratching you guys back back to sleep
at night packing his bags
yeah to some extent it depends on the
individual so everybody for me has
different needs and when you're in a
relationship you learn that person's
needs okay so when you understand what
your partner loves and what they like
then that's when you adapt it for your
relationship
okay what about you
i would say that well a lot of what she
said wasn't really submissive to be
honest it's me of actually knowing the
person like knowing what to put in their
bag
even cooking a meal isn't relatively
submissive that's more nurturing
submissive for me is part of a holistic
feminine build-up it's one of the
attributes of fame of being like
feminine and in that case scratching
your back i would say is feminine but
not so much submissive packing a bag in
itself as well isn't particularly
submissive submission for me is knowing
that the man has the power to make the
decision even though he may sort of
consult you and discuss with you any
issues in your relationship and where
you might be going that he has the final
decision so she didn't say a lot about
submiss being submissive to me then
secondly she said that she'd be
conditionally submissive some people get
it some people don't but the fact of the
matter is someone's either feminine or
they're not really so in that case to me
it seems like she'll be conditionally
feminine and to be conditionally
feminine is a bit of a red flag to me
and on top of that as well i expect she
would expect a man to be
all the time masculine so i wouldn't say
there was much submissiveness and
there's a lot of nice things being said
which i would accept and take part in
and enjoy from a partner but not really
submissive so would you say it would
have been submissive if um cam newton
was the one that requested it and then
she's going along with what he wants
yeah and that would be accepting his
decision and saying okay i'm willing to
do that for you and i agree with what
you're saying yes okay what about you
i i agree i don't think what she was
speaking was necessarily submissive i
feel like naturally as women we have
this incline when a man is your
protector and you understand your man
you are the nurturer and the submission
is a part of that and it is just
something that naturally flows out
within your relationship don't forget
submission is tailored to the individual
so and it's not tailored to the female
it's tailored to how your your partner
is because their level of submission
might be completely different to
somebody else's relationship it's for me
it comes back down to
how comfortable and how protected and
how
uh
stable your relationship is and how you
feel in that and then a woman's natural
incline to be nurturing within her
relationship is where her submission
falls
okay
just from the outside sort of looking in
i kind of agree with everything that she
said
and the reason being is she's saying
that um
you know maybe the things that she was
describing doesn't necessarily
constitute submission but i think she
was expressing that these are the things
that she does because she's in a
position where as a woman she feels like
her man is fulfilling his responsibility
she feels like this is the guy this is
the person that i'm here for this is the
one who takes all the boxes for me and
as a woman she wants to give herself to
him so that was her kind of expressing
that and i 100 agree with her when she
says that she doesn't just do that for
anybody because she can't just do that
for anybody you have to
when you're in a relationship you have
to discriminate
and the reason being is because you
can't allow any old tom dick and harry
to come into your life
the person that is for you is the one
you would submit to he doesn't have to
ask for it you will give yourself to him
because he takes your boxes and to me
that's what a relationship is it's it's
effort that is effortless you give
yourself to somebody because they are
the person who
kind of does it for you do you see what
i'm saying
and that's why when she was like i give
it to some people and not others i'm
like bang on you shouldn't give it to
anyone are you free for all
no you're not i hear what you're saying
there but in a relationship bro yeah she
should pick someone who isn't a tom dick
and harry so therefore the person she's
picked would be worthy of that
submission if she's picking tom dick and
harry's and dishing out 10 here 15 there
that's not really a good thing because
if you're naturally submissive and
feminine yeah and you're picking quality
men the actual men themselves
will appreciate that and take that on
board and may go the extra mile with you
but if you're like teasing out i might
give you a bit of this or you know it
could lead to the relationship having
negative effects yeah so i hear what
you're saying you're completely right
but i would argue that's what she's
doing precisely because she's
demonstrated that there's people i would
pick and there's people that i wouldn't
do you see what i'm saying
but um
the main point i'm trying to make is
that she's demonstrating that the
quality of being feminine can only be
given to the correct masculine
and i completely agree with that i
respect that yeah because i always hear
um on one hand guys will say well it's
conditionally feminine like we don't say
we're conditionally masculine yeah and
so i hear them when they say that but
the other hand it's like
masculinity is leadership and submission
is following that guy's leadership and
some some guys aren't competent enough
their girls want to follow them that's
correct definitely maybe she shouldn't
pick him well i she's not yeah yeah she
i mean she picked cam newton that's
pretty good she's got a good one that's
a pretty good pick
and i also just want to say i feel like
let's not forget that everybody
male female has masculine and female
energy like feminine energy and for me i
always say
certainty is what makes you a leader
and i feel like that is what is a big
factor within masculine men or women
that are a bit more in touch with their
masculine nature like the whole alpha
the the foolishness that goes around all
the time
certainty is what breeds a leader well
it's the ability to make a decision
because indecisiveness is feminine and
it doesn't necessarily mean they make
the right decision all the time but it's
it's that you're you're going to make a
decision you're going to be confident in
that decision and then whatever happens
happens you'll deal with it yeah yeah
but a lot of men can't even get to the
point where they can make a decision
yeah yeah that's what's separate and i
think
for um
a woman to be behind that decision a
hundred percent is
am i in the market okay yeah yeah it's
paramount so if you're in a relationship
and that man is making a decision you
have to be behind it because if you're
not then it breaks your relationship
you know
a lot of women downplay their part
to play in the foundations of the
relationship so the guy is leading but
you are the secondary you know like
fault behind that so if you're going
left and he's going right then the
relationship's gonna break and it allows
other people to kind of instigate and
infiltrate your relationship
and
when a man makes a decision you know he
might not be asking you for
your opinion on the matter being
comfortable with actually just listening
and
reasoning with your partner without
actually saying to them oh no you know i
don't agree this is what i think
sometimes you just have to listen and
allow a man to have his thought process
and be supportive of it because that
that support is more important than
you're actually you actually putting
food for another idea or saying i don't
agree you know just feeling hurt